Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sammasambuddhassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sammasambuddhassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sammasambuddhassam
Hommage au Bouddha, le noble bienheureux, béni et illuminé.
Donc ce soir j'aimerais parler de ce que nous appelons les obstacles.
Et ces obstacles, en réalité, contiennent toutes nos souffrances.
Et c'est comprendre comment agir contre ces hindrances
C'est la compréhension de comment gérer ces obstacles qui va être notre thérapie.
Nous pouvons diviser ces obstacles en deux types.
Ceux qui nous excitent et ceux qui nous font disparaître.
et ceux qui nous font disparaître donc ceux qui sont stimulants ont attrait aux pensées qui sont plaisantes et ceux qui sont liés aux pensées déplaisantes
Donc, prenons d'abord tous les obstacles qui créent le bonheur pour nous.
Donc, quand je parle de bonheur, bien sûr, je fais référence...
ou mauvais type de bonheur donc ce sont des choses qui nous attaquent, nous assaillent pendant la méditation comme par exemple planifier nos vacances ou bien planifier un énorme business dans le pire des cas, sauver le monde
Il y a toute cette zone des désirs érotiques et romantiques.
Toutes ces choses peuvent devenir obsessionnelles.
Et ceux d'entre vous qui ont médité pendant assez de temps, savent que vous pouvez rapidement passer des heures dans ce monde rêvé.
Et pour ceux qui ont déjà une pratique de la méditation, vous savez bien comme nous pouvons passer des heures dans ce monde-là, dans ce rayon-là.
J'ai un ami qui a passé six mois en méditation.
Et il m'a dit qu'il a passé tout son temps à planifier son voyage en Amérique du Sud.
L'ironie était qu'il n'y a jamais été.
L'ironie du sort c'est qu'il n'est jamais allé.
Donc nous devons être prudents avec ces rêves parce qu'ils sont souvent déconnectés de la réalité.
Donc comment est-ce que nous pouvons les traquer ?
Donc la première chose, c'est de ne pas être agressif envers eux.
De ne pas les voir comme des ennemis.
Mais au contraire, ils nous montrent là où sont nos faiblesses.
Et même là, nous devons rester fermes.
Donc quand nous nous réveillons hors d'une fantaisie,
L'objet de la fantaisie n'est pas important.
L'objet de notre fantaisie n'est pas important.
Que ce soit les vacances ou le business que l'on veut construire, ce n'est pas ça qui est important.
Mais c'est plutôt ce qui saisit l'esprit et s'empare de l'esprit.
C'est le pouvoir.
C'est le pouvoir, n'est-ce pas?
C'est pourquoi il est important de noter l'attitude qui cause cela.
Planifier.
Lusting.
Romanticiser.
C'est l'attitude qui cause le problème.
Donc que ce soit le désir ou d'avoir des pensées romantiques, c'est ça le problème.
Donc une fois que vous avez noté ce que l'esprit est en train de faire, vous revenez simplement au corps.
Parce que la réponse est dans le corps.
Parce que
parce que le corps est ce à travers quoi ?
l'attitude va s'exprimer va s'exprimer à travers un ressenti c'est ce que nous appelons une émotion ou un état d'âme
Donc nous allons nous plonger dans ce ressenti physique.
Oui, l'une est simplement de ressentir la texture de cette émotion ou de cet état mental.
Et notre attitude est juste de la laisser exprimer elle-même.
Donc notre attitude sera simplement de la laisser s'exprimer.
Mais si au contraire vous voulez vous en débarrasser, alors vous ajoutez une énergie supplémentaire dans le système.
Et si vous regardez ce désir de plus proche, vous allez découvrir que c'est plutôt un mouvement de ne pas vouloir.
Donc cette négativité entre également dans le système.
Donc si nous considérons comment nous supprimer
supprimons nos états mentaux donc c'est à travers l'action d'aversion ou de peur l'aversion nous fait pousser
Donc la version nous fait repousser.
Donc c'est une énergie qui va rester à l'intérieur de ce système psychophysique.
Cet organisme psychophysique.
C'est une phrase très préférée de moi.
I like saying it.
Psychophysical organism.
When we have fear, the fear makes us turn away from it.
Quand nous avons de la peur, la peur nous éloigne de cela.
So now the fear is making us ignore the feeling.
Donc la peur nous fait ignorer le ressenti.
Donc ne soyez pas surpris que quand vous rentrez dans le corps, ce qui va émerger c'est la peur ou l'aversion.
Parce qu'à cause de nos habitudes passées, nous avons construit tout un système de défense personnelle.
Et souvenez-vous, parce que nous nous ouvrons à nous-mêmes, et c'est ça l'importance de demeurer paisiblement dans l'instant présent, nous nous enseignons à être complètement ouverts
C'est de nous apprendre à être complètement ouvert.
Donc les choses à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes peuvent surgir très rapidement.
Et si cela se produit et vous vous sentez submergé, alors arrêtez la méditation.
Alors simplement arrêtez la méditation.
Allez marcher.
Ou placez votre attention sur une partie du corps qui est neutre.
Comme vos mains.
Et puis attendez jusqu'à ce que l'équanimité revienne.
C'est vrai de le dire, malheureusement.
Malheureusement, il est vrai de dire que les choses vont beaucoup plus mal avant d'aller mieux.
Mais le produit final est merveilleux.
Donc, quand il s'agit de choses que nous appréhendons, nous entrons dans le corps et nous restons avec les sentiments d'excitement.
Tant que nous allons à la rencontre des choses qui sont plaisantes, alors nous restons à l'intérieur du corps avec ces ressentis.
Et nous attendons patiemment que cela s'épuise d'eux-mêmes.
Maintenant, si vous n'avez pas expérimenté cela, vous voyez, c'est une expérience très importante.
Et si vous n'avez pas encore expérimenté cela, alors c'est une expérience importante à faire.
Parce que quand vous réalisez que la guérison survient quand vous ne faites rien, ça c'est une grande compréhension en réalisation.
Quand je dis « ne faites rien », je veux dire « ne faites rien sur la situation ».
Donc quand je dis ne rien faire, c'est ne rien faire par rapport à la situation.
La seule chose que nous avons à faire, c'est d'être ouvert à l'expérience.
C'est comme cela que le cœur peut se guérir.
Donc considérez le corps.
Quand vous vous découpez,
qui guérit le corps ?
notre travail c'est de garder la plaie propre le corps lui se guérit tout seul nous n'avons pas besoin de nous occuper des cellules c'est pareil avec le cœur
Et c'est la même chose avec le cœur.
Il suffit de garder l'espace propre, juste avec l'attention juste.
Et le cœur peut se guérir tout seul.
l'état naturel du cœur est paisible c'est la quiétude ça c'est l'état naturel du cœur
C'est seulement par une compréhension fausse que nous avons créé ces turbulences.
Les autres types de turbulences auxquelles nous avons affaire sont de type négatif.
comme la colère, la peur, l'anxiété, la dépression.
Donc il y a une longue liste de misères que l'être humain se crée.
Donc ces émotions veulent s'exprimer.
Et vous ressentez une relâche quand vous les permettez d'exprimer à travers un rêve, une fantaisie.
Mais si nous regardons attentivement, chaque fois que ces états mentaux s'expriment à travers un pattern de pensée,
Mais si nous regardons de manière plus proche, à chaque fois que nous permettons cela, nous permettons ces émotions de s'exprimer à travers ces rêves, en réalité, elles se développent.
Un exemple évident, que je suis sûre que vous avez tous fait l'expérience,
Le matin, quelqu'un dit quelque chose qui vous irrite un petit peu.
Mais vous le négligez.
Ensuite, il vient l'heure du café.
Et pendant que vous avez du café,
Et pendant que vous prenez votre café, le souvenir ressurgit.
Comment est-ce qu'ils ont pu me faire cela ?
Comment est-ce qu'ils ont fait blablabla ?
Et au moment du repas du midi, c'est juste une énorme tempête.
Vous n'arrivez pas à dormir.
Vous devez prendre des pilules.
Cette personne vous a insulté juste une fois.
Mais vous vous êtes assuré qu'elle l'a fait au moins mille fois de plus.
Et vous avez reçu une terrible révenge sur eux.
Vous vous êtes vengé.
Vous vous êtes vengé d'une manière terrible.
Et même quand nous sommes en colère, comme nous brûlons la porte, nous chantons, nous ressentons une relâche.
Et pourtant lorsque nous sommes en colère et que nous claquons une porte, nous sentons un soulagement.
Mais ce que nous devons reconnaître pendant la méditation, c'est qu'en réalité cela est une complaisance, une indulgence.
Et pour cette raison, nous employons la même technique.
A partir du moment où nous constatons qu'il y a de la colère, de l'anxiété ou la dépression, nous notons simplement et nous revenons encore.
Et nous permettons à cet état mental d'exprimer lui-même comme un ressenti.
Et nous permettons à cet état mental de s'exprimer en tant que ressenti.
Bien sûr, cela est difficile.
Parce que certaines de ces émotions sont vraiment très douloureuses.
Donc comme je le disais, si nous pouvons rester présents jusqu'au moment où cela disparaît, donc nous avons la confiance que ce processus en réalité nous guérit.
Le quatrième obstacle s'appelle l'agitation et tout ce qui a trait à la honte et à la culpabilité.
Quand nous parlons d'agitation, à nouveau il y a deux types.
La première, c'est simplement l'esprit qui s'agite, qui se balade.
Et à nouveau, il nous faut pratiquer la patience.
Dès que nous notons l'agitation, nous revenons au corps.
Et si nous ne ressentons aucune agitation dans le corps, alors nous revenons à la respiration.
et à peine nous sommes à la respiration que nous sommes déjà perdus dans l'esprit et cela se produit pendant une assise, la deuxième, la troisième et nous pensons que la méditation n'est pas bonne
Et nous pensons que la méditation ne vaut rien.
Mais c'est cela la méditation.
Donc nous permettons à l'esprit d'être agité, de s'exprimer et puis ensuite nous revenons au corps.
Et de revenir dans l'instant présent, c'est cela la pratique.
Si cela se passe pendant une semaine, pendant un an, pendant toute notre vie, c'est ça la pratique.
Et c'est une bonne pratique.
Si le méditateur dit que noter un rêve de l'intensité pense à lui-même, c'est intéressant.
Si le méditant note ce que l'esprit est en train de faire, et se dit à lui-même, ça c'est intéressant, et continue le rêve, ça c'est une mauvaise pratique.
Et l'on devrait se sentir culpé et malheureux.
Et on devra se sentir coupable et honteux.
C'est une grande perte de temps.
Donc, quand l'esprit est agité, il suffit juste d'avoir la patience de revenir encore et encore.
Considère, du moment où tu t'attends,
à partir du moment où vous vous réveillez le matin jusqu'au moment où vous vous couchez le soir, est-ce que l'esprit s'arrête un moment ?
Non.
Ensuite nous venons de la méditation et nous l'attendons à s'arrêter.
Et puis nous venons méditer et nous attendons à ce qu'il s'arrête.
C'est juste impossible.
Donc tout ce que nous faisons ici et maintenant doit être intégré dans notre vie de tous les jours.
Si, vous savez, dans ces moments pendant le jour, quand vous n'êtes pas en train de faire quelque chose,
Donc si pendant ces instants de la journée où vous ne faites rien en particulier, marcher de là à là-bas, en haut, en bas les escaliers, ces petits moments entre les deux, nous laissons la tête s'éloigner.
Nous laissons l'esprit s'échapper.
C'est pour ça que nous souffrons tant ici dans la salle de méditation.
Et donc, dans la vie de tous les jours, à partir du moment où nous nous apercevons que l'esprit s'évade, nous le ramenons ici et maintenant.
Si vous le voyez comme une bataille, cela l'exhauste
Mais si vous considérez cela comme une bataille, à ce moment-là, c'est épuisant.
Mais par contre, si vous voyez cela comme une détente, comme un moment paisible, à ce moment-là, vous voulez le faire.
Donc si vous vous surprenez à courir en haut des escaliers avec l'esprit dans tous ses états, dans toutes les directions, ce que j'espère n'arrivera jamais ici, donc amenez dans votre esprit ce joli mot anglais, stop.
Ah, ce « pe » met une fin à tout.
et commencer à nouveau.
L'agitation du corps.
C'est parfois très difficile à travailler avec, mais c'est plus facile que la tête.
C'est parfois difficile de travailler avec, mais c'est quand même plus facile que l'agitation de l'esprit.
Et la règle, c'est ne pas bouger.
Sous aucune circonstance, ne bougez pas.
Donc vous êtes assis ici, et le corps veut être là-bas.
Donc vous vous détendez autour de l'agitation.
Assurez-vous que les mâchoires soient détendues, les épaules soient détendues, les mains soient détendues.
de sorte que l'agitation est prisonnière dans le corps.
Et puis ensuite, continuer à bouger la tension de manière à ce qu'elle ne soit pas prisonnière dans le corps.
Qu'elle ne soit pas prise dans le corps.
Qu'elle ne soit pas prise dans l'agitation.
Et parfois, vous pouvez mettre votre attention sur une partie neutre du corps.
Parfois, vous pouvez mettre l'attention sur une partie neutre du corps, comme vos pieds.
Les pieds sont généralement neutres.
Et puis attendez que l'équanimité arrive.
Et puis ensuite, vous pouvez retourner à l'agitation.
Cela fonctionne aussi si vous êtes très restreint, sans pouvoir dormir.
Cela marche aussi si vous êtes très agité et vous n'arrivez pas à vous endormir.
Vous adoptez une position confortable et refusez de bouger.
Et simplement déplacer l'attention autour du corps.
Et vous pouvez trouver que vous êtes soudainement au sommeil.
Vous êtes parti.
Et tout à coup, vous serez endormi.
C'est parti.
La raison pour cela, c'est que l'opposé de l'agitation, c'est la somnolence.
Doulness in the head and lethargy in the body.
Donc la somnolence dans la tête et la léthargie dans le corps.
Et ceux-là sont des états d'esprit authentiques.
Elles sont aussi importantes que la dépression, l'anxiété et tout le reste.
Parce que cela est causé par ces énergies qui vont vers l'intérieur.
Parce que cela est causé par ces énergies allant vers l'intérieur.
Comme dans l'univers, nous avons des étoiles qui explosent et puis des trous noirs.
Donc l'esprit va tout à coup imploser à l'intérieur de lui-même.
Maintenant, il y a une fatigue naturelle.
Alors bien sûr, il y a aussi une fatigue naturelle.
Et l'esprit a besoin de se reposer.
Mais ce dont nous parlons ici, c'est l'extra.
Et nous avons développé, dans le sommeil et la laziness, une route d'escapement.
Et donc nous avons développé à travers le sommeil et la paresse un échappatoire.
Donc, d'abord, comme tous ces plaisirs, ils sont plaisurables en eux-mêmes.
Donc, comme les plaisirs, ils sont aussi plaisants en soi.
Par exemple, dimanche matin, quand nous restons dans cet état subliminal...
Just on that little wave of not being awake and not being asleep.
Nous nous sommes réveillés mais juste pas complètement et nous restons dans cet état entre deux.
This is very pleasurable, correct?
C'est très plaisant, n'est-ce pas?
But unfortunately, we are seeking happiness in oblivion.
Mais en réalité, nous recherchons le bonheur dans l'oubli.
It's a pleasant place to be
Et aussi, quand nous entrons dans l'inconscience, au moins ici, il n'y a pas de souffrance.
Malheureusement, nous continuons de nous réveiller.
Mais nous avons toujours dans nous une petite route d'escapement.
Mais nous avons quand même en nous-mêmes un petit échappatoire.
Donc quand nous nous sentons un petit peu déprimés, un petit peu nous ennuyant, alors nous choisissons un canapé confortable et puis nous commençons à penser, à divaguer un peu.
Et on va vers cet état de somnolence.
Donc, est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose de merveilleux que lorsque nous venons méditer, tout ce que nous pouvons faire est dormir ?
Oui, je ne peux pas penser à quelque chose de plus embêtant que de regarder le sommeil.
Je ne peux rien trouver d'autre de plus ennuyant que de regarder la respiration.
C'est très ennuyant.
Alors, je vais m'endormir.
Et cela aussi, vous devez l'intégrer dans votre vie de tous les jours.
Vous devez regarder le lit comme un ennemi.
Vous devez regarder votre lit comme un ennemi.
Tous les fauteuils comme des dangers potentiels.
Alors que faisons-nous quand cela nous arrive pendant la méditation ?
Donc c'est ok si nous nous endormons et continuellement nous vacillons.
À partir du moment où, lorsque nous nous réveillons, nous redressons la colonne.
Et que nous pénétrions à l'intérieur de cette sensation de somnolence dans la tête.
Ou bien cette sensation de lourdeur dans le corps.
Et continuer à bouger l'attention tout comme vous le faites dans le cas de l'agitation.
et cela va permettre à l'énergie de revenir dans la connaissance dans la présence, l'attention et pour les personnes qui le savent et celles qui ne le savent pas encore vous serez étonnés de voir à quel point il est possible d'être clair dans cet état de somnolence c'est comme une lumière dans un feu
C'est comme une lumière à l'intérieur du brouillard.
Donc ça dit tout simplement aux méditants qu'il y a cette somnolence, la léthargie.
Mais la connexion avec l'indulgence a été coupée.
Donc c'est cette indulgence subtile qui crée cette somnolence dans la connaissance.
Le manque de clarté dans le fait de connaître, de savoir.
Parce que le habit est de devenir la douleur.
Parce que l'habitude c'est de devenir la somnolence.
Donc à travers tous ces obstacles, il est possible de retrouver cette position à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes.
La position de l'observateur objectif.
The objective feeler.
De celui qui ressent objectivement.
A nice phrase is the observation post.
Une phrase qui est intéressante, c'est observation post.
Post.
Ah voilà, post observation.
Le post d'observation.
Yes.
Comme sur un bateau, vous avez la vigie.
En haut du mât, voilà, qui observe.
Puis tout en haut.
Donc vous êtes en haut et vous regardez vers le bas.
Donc vous essayez toujours de trouver dans vous-même cette position de la poste d'observation.
Donc vous allez toujours essayer de rechercher en vous-même ce poste d'observation.
Et à partir de là, nous pénétrons à l'intérieur du corps, à l'intérieur des sensations.
Donc j'ai abordé maintenant tout ce qui était en lien avec les plaisirs.
Tout ce qui était en lien avec l'aversion.
Tout ce qui avait attrait à l'aversion.
En incluant la peur, la dépression, etc.
Nous avons parlé de la lethargie et de l'insomnolence.
Et nous avons parlé de l'agitation.
Une petite chose que le Bouddha attache à l'agitation est la culpabilité, la haine, la remorse, tous ces sentiments autour de l'agitation.
Donc, ce que le Bouddha rattache à l'agitation, c'est tout ce qui a trait à la culpabilité, au remords, à la honte.
Donc, quand ces états apparaissent, eh bien, traitez-les comme des états négatifs.
Donc nous ressortons de la fantaisie, de la pensée, pour pénétrer à l'intérieur de ces ressentis.
Donc si vous pouvez résoudre quelque chose que vous avez fait de mal, et bien faites-le après la retraite.
Et si cela n'est pas possible, alors comprenez cela comme étant la conséquence d'une mauvaise action.
Et de simplement demeurer avec cela, c'est demeurer avec le karma.
Donc il n'y a pas besoin de nous punir au-delà de cela.
Enfin, il y a le problème du doute.
Et pour terminer, il y a le problème du doute.
Le Bouddha souhaite que nous ayons un certain type de doute qu'il appelle l'émerveillement.
C'est l'émotion du philosophe qui est à l'intérieur de nous.
Le scientifique à l'intérieur de nous.
Donc, tout ce que le Bouddha nous dit est mis en hypothèse.
C'est pour nous prouver que c'est vrai pour nous.
Donc le but c'est de voir de vérifier si pour nous cela est vrai, si cela nous correspond.
Doubt, therefore, in the Buddha, we can, as it were, put aside through confidence.
le doute dans le Bouddha, le doute dans le Bouddha, en posant confiance dans son enseignement.
Nous pouvons mettre ce doute de côté en mettant notre confiance dans ses enseignements, au moins pour ce retreat, vous voyez.
Au moins pendant cette retraite.
Vous n'avez pas besoin de vous engager à vie.
Vous pouvez le faire petit à petit.
Donc manquer de confiance dans l'enseignant.
Dieu nous en préserve.
Merci.
L'enseignant de vipassana c'est seulement quelqu'un qui donne des instructions.
Et si les instructions ne marchent pas, alors nous remettons l'enseignant en question.
Et s'il y a toujours un sentiment d'insatisfaction, de malheureux, après avoir considéré cela avec prudence, nous allons trouver un autre enseignant.
Mais je crois que la plupart d'entre nous, nous souffrons d'un manque de confiance en nous-mêmes.
Donc, nous traiterons cela de la même manière que nous traiterons tous les autres états mentaux négatifs.
Quand le doute arrive, le doute sceptique,
quand le doute surgit, le doute sceptique, cela est basé sur une certaine forme de peur ou d'aversion.
La peur de l'échec, la peur de la critique.
Et cela, si une personne a cela, elle peut dépasser ses vies.
Et si une personne a cela, ça peut... Miner.
Donc ça peut miner toute leur vie.
Par exemple, si un travail se présente à vous et vous pose la question, est-ce que je peux le faire, oui ou non, je ne sais pas.
Même avant que vous puissiez faire une décision, le travail est perdu.
Et avant même que vous preniez la décision, le travail est loin.
Par exemple, si vous voulez vous engager dans une relation sérieuse, vous posez la question, est-ce que c'est bien, est-ce que ça donne personne, etc. ?
Avant même que vous n'ayez pris la décision, la personne en a marre, elle est partie.
Donc ce doute sceptique peut vraiment miner, saper la vie de quelqu'un.
Et surtout les personnes spirituelles.
Parce que c'est la même chose.
Sans confiance, l'un ne fait pas l'action.
Donc c'est la même chose, quand il n'y a pas de confiance en soi, nous n'agissons pas.
Donc chacun d'entre vous ici doit avoir confiance en la pratique, sinon vous ne seriez pas ici.
Mais ce qui se passe, c'est que sur la durée, nous ne nous rendons pas vraiment compte que nous progressons, que nous nous développons.
Contrairement à lorsque nous avons juste commencé, là, parfois nous pouvons voir des progrès assez rapides.
Et puis là, nous commençons à perdre la confiance.
Donc faites attention à ces instants, à ces moments où vous n'avez pas l'impression d'avancer.
Donc c'est comme ces vieux marins qui étaient dans cet état de...
Vous savez les doldrums ?
L'équateur où il n'y a pas de vent.
Il n'y a pas de vent et les marins ont l'impression qu'ils n'avancent pas, qu'ils ne vont nulle part.
Mais, sans les connaître, la couronne de la mer les prend.
Mais sous eux, le courant de l'océan les emmène.
Mais si vous continuez de pratiquer, vous verrez que vous avancez.
Donc faites attention aux doutes de soi.
Donc nous avons ces cinq domaines de négativité en nous-mêmes.
Les plaisirs et les aversions.
La somnolence et la léthargie.
toute l'agitation à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes, et le doute sceptique.
Et si nous devions faire un constat simple sur comment gérer tout cela, dans la méditation ici et dans Vipassana,
et bien c'est de sortir de l'esprit pour aller dans le corps et permettre à ces états mentaux de s'exprimer et dans cette expression ils finissent par s'épuiser et la dernière chose à dire c'est que cette énergie ne disparaît pas seulement
Et la dernière chose à mentionner, c'est que cette énergie ne disparaît pas.
Mais elle est transformée.
Très naturellement, tous ces plaisirs donnent lieu à des plaisirs plus wholesome.
Donc, tout naturellement, ces plaisirs vont faire la place à des qualités plus saintes, bénéfiques.
Toutes les aversions vont se transformer en leur opposé.
Haine en amour, cruauté en compassion.
Selfishness to generosity.
L'égoïsme en générosité.
Et toutes ces énergies qui étaient somnolence et léthargie deviennent pures.
Et le doute devient une confiance ferme.
Vous êtes aussi en train de commencer un processus de transformation.
Voilà.
Donc, si vous voulez faire des méditations de marche,